what he discovered as he opened me up uh  is that this one had fully ruptured the  right one but Lord knows how that thing  ruptured I mean what like was it the  pressure of breath the breast milk I  don't I don't know if it's if it's  ruptured like Lord knows what's seeping  through my body only had one set 12  years I remember someone tell they were  silicone even though I was like healthy  minded at the time not like I am today  it was still a bad aesthetic for me so I  was like I don't care if saline safer I  want I want him to feel real did you  even know silicone to be unsafe I knew  there were risks silicone has more risk  than saline because if somehow they  leaked which is very unlikely it could  be toxic to your body but you would know  and then you could get them removed and  it wouldn't be like tragic